antonio y bernardo atraparon un lagarto
en su patio trasero si el cuerpo del
lagarto mide 17 sobre 8 decímetros y
esto lo vamos a ocupar y su cola mide
diez sobre ocho decímetros eso también
lo vamos a ocupar la pregunta es cuánto
miden juntos el cuerpo y la cola del
lagarto y si te das cuenta esto es muy
parecido al lagarto que atraparon
antonio y bernardo y si estas unidades
están dadas en decímetros vamos a ver a
qué equivale el cuerpo del lagarto y su
cola el cuerpo el lagarto mide 17 sobre
8 decímetros 17 sobre 8 decímetros es
más o menos tomarnos
veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 en cada uno de
estos enteros está dividido en ocho
partes por lo tanto si me tomo 17
octavos decímetros me voy a tomar
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 y
17 y si te das cuenta es equivalente a
lo que mide el largo del cuerpo de este
lagarto este lagarto mide de cuerpo 17
sobre 8 decímetros que es justo este
largo que tenemos aquí es más déjame
ponerlo con este color todo este largo
todo este largo de aquí son 17 sobre 8
decímetros todo esto de aquí es lo que
equivale el cuerpo del lagarto ahora
además me dicen que su cola mide 10
sobre 8 decímetros por ciento aquí le
voy a poner 17 octavos decímetros ahora
fijémonos en la otra parte la otra parte
dice que mide 10 sobre 8 decímetros que
es la cola entonces a partir de aquí voy
a contar 10
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
es decir que justo por acá es donde
llegan la cola del lagarto y si te das
cuenta es cierto hasta que llega a su
cola es decir que todo esto todo esto de
aquí es lo que mide su cola que por
cierto quedamos que era 10 sobre 8 ok
ahora si queremos saber cuánto en total
miden juntos el cuerpo y la escuela de
lagartóns pues esencialmente lo que hay
que tomarnos es la suma de estos dos
diecisiete octavos más diez octavos y
esto va a ser igual lo padre es que
tenemos un denominador común que es 8
por lo tanto no voy a poner aquí abajo
como es el denominador común y lo que
hay que hacer es tomarnos la suma de los
dos numeradores 17 ya esto le voy a
sumar 10
y esto lo voy a sumar 10 y esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que 17 10 27 27
octavos ahora sí puedo decir que el
cuerpo y la cola del lagarto' miden
juntos 27 sobre 8 decímetros y si esto
lo queremos ver como un numero mixto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 por 824 tres
enteros tres octavos tres octavos ocho
por 324 3 es 27 y tú lo puedes
corroborar aquí tenemos un entero dos
enteros tres enteros y uno dos tres
octavos que es justo lo que queríamos
en total el cuerpo y la cuerda de este
lagarto miden 27 sobre 8 o lo que es lo
mismo tres enteros tres octavos hasta la
próxima